well this holiday season you could give
the gift of a new car from Chapman Dodge
Chrysler Jeep Ram the sponsors of
today's segment and here to tell us all
about the special deals we have our
friend the president of Nevada
operations Don Hamrick Don so great to
see you nice to see you as well last
time I saw you we were cooking in the
kitchen for Thanksgiving now we're
talking about the holidays so why are
the holidays a good time maybe to get a
new car you know it's the end of the
year and so from our standpoint we're
just going to do everything we can to
make sure our customers get the car they
want we're going to help them get
everything on their wish list and that's
what's about it's all about the wish
list right now you're like the Santa of
cars right we'd like to think of
ourselves that way so yeah whatever
people feel is going to be best for them
we're going to make that happen so
people come in what specials can they
maybe expect to see so in answer to that
wish list first we've got a great
selection it's been so tough to get cars
these days but we're in a fortunate
situation that we do have those second
zero percent interest everybody's
talking about how expensive it is to get
financing now and interest rates have
been going up and that's true but we
have zero percent interest for as long
as six years 72 months discounts up to
ten thousand dollars and no payments are
you ready for this until spring of next
year wow so you can buy the car get the
car you want and not have to make a
payment until March or so of next year
gosh that has to just be so reassuring
for people who come in and are maybe a
little overwhelmed by the process do you
find that your customers really
gravitate towards that I mean that is a
huge special it's a huge special and you
know for us it's about making it easy
for our clients because you're right
they only buy a car once every few years
we sell you know hundreds a month and we
just want to make that easy it's a
process that if you have a professional
helping it makes it so much more
comfortable well you guys are obviously
doing something right you continue to
grow you just open a new dealership too
Ray tell us about that we will so our
new store take a look at that picture
Jillian this is our new Jeep store a
completely exclusive store for Jeep
that's opening on East Sahara wow in the
beginning of next year we think January
or February and and it's coming along
just beautifully every time I go through
I get excited and that's right on the
heels of the store we just opened in
July it's an all-new Dodge Chrysler Ram
store so we've been very fortunate in
our community Las Vegas has been great
to us yeah and we just continue to see
you grow and it's so exciting to see and
now is the time before the end of the
year it's the perfect holiday present
who doesn't want a new car with a nice
big red bow on top the end of the tree
we'll just put it under there make them
a surprise we've done that so many times
and it's so exciting to see I know I
would be excited to see that Don thank
you so much for being here it's always
so great to see you hope you enjoy your
holidays thank you to Chapman Dodge
Chrysler Jeep Ram for sponsoring this
segment they are located at the address
on your screen 3470 Boulder Highway just
south of Sahara you can call it
702-457-1061 or visit
lasvegasdodge.com for more Chapman is
offering specials on every new vehicle
including no payments until that spring
of 2023 up to ten thousand dollars in
discounts and zero percent financing for
72 months Las Vegas now we'll be right
back
[Music]